[Música]
si usted pensaba que había visto todo en
cuanto a la crisis peruana estaba muy
equivocado este país volvió a vivir un
remesón político de Gran calado que
abrió las puertas a un nuevo capítulo en
la historia del país Todo comenzó con
estas declaraciones escuchemos
convocar en el más breve plazo a
elecciones para un nuevo congreso con
facultades constituyentes para elaborar
una nueva constitución en un plazo no
mayor de nueve meses a partir de la
fecha y hasta que se instaure el nuevo
el nuevo congreso de la república se
gobernará mediante decretos ley
La pregunta es cuánto durará ese nuevo
episodio les presento entonces un
resumen de los hechos recientes
ocurridos allí en Perú esta nueva crisis
dentro de la crisis comenzó con el
anuncio de Castillo como lo veíamos de
disolver El Congreso y la instalación de
un gobierno de emergencia con el que
Castillo buscaba gobernar por decreto
convocar a nuevas elecciones
parlamentarias y redactar una nueva
constitución solo unas horas después los
parlamentarios en una sesión
extraordinaria aprobaron la destitución
de Castillo para el cierre de la jornada
Dina boluarte asumió como presidente
interina ante el pleno del congreso
boluarte tiene una enorme tarea por
delante un enorme reto liderar un país
prácticamente ingobernable y generar
consensos entre los sectores políticos
de ese país estas fueron sus palabras al
ser juramentada en el cargo escuchemos
las que me toca y mi primera invocación
como no podía ser de otra manera es
convocar
a la más amplia unidad de todas y todos
los peruanos a esta hora entonces uno se
pregunta cómo está la situación allí en
Perú entonces veamos Pues bueno Pedro
Castillo está detenido por las
autoridades la fiscalía peruana ya
inició una investigación para abrir un
caso en su contra por las declaraciones
dadas y podría ser acusado por delitos
de rebelión y conspiración en resumen
Pedro Castillo se suma a esta lista ya
de presidentes de Perú que no logran
terminar el mandato estuvo solamente 16
meses en el poder enfrentó dos mociones
de censura que no prosperaron en la
votación pero esta última la tercera que
tal parece fue la vencida encontró
argumentos suficientes para que los
legisladores votaran ciento un votos a
favor de la destitución por incapacidad
moral permanente ahora una mujer la
primera en la historia de Perú está al
mando de este país Dina boluarte tiene
como lo decía ese reto de unir un país
que está completamente polarizado a
nivel político y a nivel social también
Buscar una forma de salir de esta crisis
política generar concesos y sobre todo
darle rumbo a Perú para que tenga un
Norte definido tiene hasta el 2016 fecha
en la que debería de haber terminado el
mandato Castillo para poderlo lograr que
tanto margen de gobernabilidad entonces
tendrá boluarte está ahora en el poder
Pero la pregunta que surge es Por cuánto
tiempo cuánto pasará para que el
congreso de ese país inicie los trámites
para también destituirla como ha pasado
con los otros mandatarios pues vamos a
analizar la situación en Perú aquí en el
debate de France 24 y para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a
Alexandra ames ella es politóloga y jefa
del observatorio de la escuela de
gestión pública de la Universidad del
Pacífico ubicada en la Ciudad de Lima y
también está con nosotros Gabriela Vega
Franco ella es politóloga y magíster en
gobierno y Administración pública
nuestros televidentes ustedes ya lo
saben son parte de este debate también
son importantes todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas que las pueden hacer A
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el debate_f24
arroba santilogo la etiqueta para que
dejen los comentarios numeral el debate
f-24 no olviden también que todos los
contenidos del programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn agradezco a todas
las personas que nos están escuchando a
través de estas plataformas Pues muy
bien comenzamos el debate Entonces le
doy la bienvenida a Alexandra Gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en el
programa en France 24 en el debate y
quiero comenzar con la opinión general
Alexandra Qué opinión tiene usted qué
análisis puede hacer de estos hechos que
tuvieron lugar en Perú y cómo entender
lo que ha hecho el ahora expresidente
Pedro Castillo
Bueno gracias por la invitación la
verdad es que en este momento todos los
peruanos nos preguntamos
qué ha pasado realmente en el
razonamiento de Pedro Castillo para dar
un comunicado como este sin tener el
apoyo de las fuerzas armadas y el apoyo
político necesario para encaminar un
cierre del Congreso inconstitucional por
supuesto pero de una manera exitosa no
esto ha sido un mal cálculo por su lado
que probablemente vamos a entender en
los próximos meses pero lo que toca
ahora es ser conscientes de qué pasa no
Cuál es el siguiente paso Porque si bien
hemos tenido un día bastante intenso con
varios shocks y anuncios realmente bien
drásticos en términos de estabilidad
institucional Lo cierto es que una
vacancia presidencial no va a solucionar
la crisis en la que estamos inmersos
desde hace ya Algunos años y si bien es
cierto también que la permanencia de
Pedro Castillo significaba un costo muy
alto para la propia institucionalidad
del país es importante que los peruanos
ahora pensemos en cómo salimos de esta
crisis
sin tener que ver a Dina boluarte como
el símbolo de tapar el sol con un dedo
me quedo con frases como un mal cálculo
del presidente o ex presidente Pedro
castillo y la vacancia no soluciona la
situación política que está viviendo
esta crisis política esta crisis dentro
de la crisis Ya lo vamos a conversar
Alexandra le doy la bienvenida también a
Gabriela allí en la Ciudad de Lima para
conocer su opinión Gabriela bienvenida
su opinión su análisis sobre estos
hechos ocurridos en Perú en las últimas
horas y también por esa decisión del
expresidente Pedro castillo de hacer
este anuncio
sin tener respaldos políticos
Buenos días y y es un placer estar con
ustedes pero no tanto por las razones
por las que nos encontramos creo que
coincido con Alexandra en el análisis
respecto de una Clara desconexión con la
realidad al tomar una decisión
inconstitucional y legal
antidemocrática como el cierre del
Congreso pero no solo el cierre del
Congreso no recordemos que el el
expresidente Castillo en sus
declaraciones señala la disolución del
Congreso la instalación de este gobierno
de emergencia pero también la
reestructuración del poder ejecutivo y
todo el sistema de justicia en general
el tribunal constitucional junta
Nacional de Justicia que son nuestros
organismos autónomos con lo cual era una
afrenta no de ejecutivo contra
legislativo sino de ejecutivo el
gobierno en contra todo el sistema
peruano de
balances y pesos y contrapesos de
poderes del Estado no
Considero que parte de este relato
respecto en el caso peruano en el cual
hemos tenido en seis años seis
presidentes
diferentes
Tiene dos caras no la primera una
evidente y
incertidumbre inestabilidad
mucho daño al aparato del Estado a las
políticas públicas que estoy segura
Alexandra podrá comentar también más
adelante pero también
un un país que ha decidido no aceptar la
impunidad y creo que en este espacio
deberíamos hacer el esfuerzo también por
por mirar las la superposición de dos
fenómenos no un congreso que
efectivamente o una posición que
efectivamente intentó retirar del poder
a Pedro Castillo desde incluso antes que
este sumara la presidencia pero también
un presidente
que intentó cotar
y controlar los poderes del estado que
excedían a sus funciones y que entonces
En definitiva debía ser detenido no creo
que
lo he hecho por el expresidente la
mañana de ayer
cambió el escenario que que teníamos y y
En definitiva se han tomado las acciones
que correspondían para detener este este
embate contra las las instituciones
democráticas Gabriela continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda la inversa y quiero
que empecemos esta discusión ya
entendiendo las posiciones y el análisis
que tienen en general de toda la
situación que se ha presentado en Perú
Hablemos del personaje principal de esta
historia Pedro Castillo que le espera
entonces a este expresidente a partir de
ahora a partir de estos hechos ocurridos
que le puede esperar a él enfrentando a
la justicia porque claramente también
hay una necesidad y un hambre digamos
así de las instituciones y de los
peruanos de Justicia que es lo que han
venido reclamando no solamente ahora
sino a lo largo muchos años y Tal parece
que a quien le ha caído ese peso va a
ser a Pedro Castillo teniendo Obviamente
si así lo lo determina la justicia la
culpa de muchas de las cosas que se le
está acusando ya lo dirá la justicia
peruana no me corresponde a mí decirlo
si lo es o no pero pero hay una hay un
hambre de la institucionalidad y de los
peruanos por justicia
sin duda hemos tenido eh expresidentes
ejecutivos y funcionarios incluso no
solo a nivel nacional sino a nivel
municipal y regional que han dado claras
muestras de falta de respeto a la
democracia
acusaciones gravísimas de corrupción y
creo que el caso de Pedro Castillo va a
ir desde elucidando por la justicia como
tú bien has señalado no tenemos
diferentes carpetas Fiscales abiertas en
su contra por delitos de encubrimiento y
obstrucción a la justicia en la
detención de un exministro de
transportes y comunicaciones de sus
exsecretarios general de palacio de
gobierno de su sobrino tenemos
acusaciones en contra ascensos
irregulares también el caso último que
vimos la mañana de ayer de hecho
mientras él hace su anuncio
en un nuevo escándalo en el Ministerio
de vivienda Entonces tenemos diferentes
niveles de acusaciones de casos de
corrupción en los que ya en la última
fase de estas
corroboraciones y estas declaraciones
que han hecho colaboradores eficaces te
le involucra directamente Pero tenemos
este caso ya flagrante de las
declaraciones de ayer con lo cual
Pedro Castillo enfrenta una serie de
investigaciones que tomarán tiempo más
largo Pero hoy ya no solo se trata esto
sino se trata de una detención en
flagrancia que es lo que vivimos ayer en
las calles de Lima la detención en manos
de la policía y hoy ya la evaluación de
su
denuncia
Alexandra Cuál es su opinión qué le
espera entonces a Pedro castillo y y le
extiendo un poco más la pregunta este
era la mejor salida que tenía él para la
crisis que llevaba presentando en estos
16 meses de gobierno era el mejor paso
que podía dar el presidente O de verdad
Pedro Castillo estaba consciente que
este era un paso que le podía solucionar
el escenario político hay quienes dicen
que claramente esta fue la evidencia de
su desconocimiento de la
institucionalidad y de la gobernabilidad
y del peso que representa ser un
presidente de un país mostraba
desconocimiento precisamente del
proceder legal y de la situación
pues cualquier decisión que él pueda
haber tomado iba a conducir Sin lugar a
dudas a ser detenido el el yo creo que
sí era consciente de que él iba a
terminar su mandato y que iba a salir de
palacio de gobierno con embarcado no
perseguido por la justicia sin embargo
Dentro de este proceso de polarización
en el que nos hemos encontrado la
narrativa que su gobierno ha creado y
que me parece el mismo se la ha creído
eh va alrededor de la lucha de clases y
de una derecha que lo persigue
constantemente lo cual dentro del país
tenemos que reconocer que hemos tenido
una derecha dentro del Congreso bastante
obstruccionista Por cierto pero lo
cierto Es que Castillo no ha sido capaz
de enmendar sus propios errores y
derrumbar el país con las políticas
públicas adecuadas para cumplir con las
promesas electorales a favor de los más
pobres del país en lugar de Eso lo único
que hizo victimizarse Y eso le impidió
tener la claridad suficiente para tener
mejores salidas a favor del país si él
hubiese actuado con un interés Genuino
de realmente implementar políticas
públicas para cerrar las brechas de
desigualdad hubiese sido la historia
distinta para él no hoy día él está
percibido la justicia y no es ninguna
novedad como dice Gabriela Vega Tenemos
también gobernadores regionales y
alcaldes que están en esta situación y
que no han podido terminar su mandato eh
Y esto es algo que puede generarnos
mucha desilusión de hecho la corrupción
y la crisis de desconfianza en las
instituciones son dos fenómenos que se
retroalimentan y que generan el
populismo que finalmente termina por
fortalecer esta polarización que tenemos
No necesariamente alrededor de las ideas
sino de un otros versus en nosotros no
Alexandra usted habla de la
victimización de Pedro Castillo a lo
largo de estos 16 meses prácticamente su
gobierno se volvió una lucha día a día
para defenderse de la oposición y de las
acusaciones que todos los días
reventaban por diferentes causas motivos
y sectores aquí hubo una persecución
contra el presidente o claramente
había una incapacidad para gobernar por
parte del mandatario y cito a dos
presidentes latinoamericanos el
presidente de México y el presidente de
Colombia que han criticado a las élites
políticas peruanas por llevar el país a
esta situación por llevar a la
destitución de castillo y e incluso
desde Bogotá el gobierno del presidente
Petro dijo que él prácticamente se vio
encerrado y que se vio en la obligación
de tener que asumir esta posición porque
eso fue lo que lo llevaron hubo una
persecución
es una combinación de las dos cosas sin
lugar a dudas desde antes de que Pedro
Castillo juramentara como presidente ya
se hablaba de una vacancia o incluso
peor del no reconocimiento electoral de
la decisión de la población peruana de
una parte de la población peruana de
haberlo elegido como presidente no
entonces
estaba clarísimo que dentro de la
derecha y dentro de la oposición nunca
hubo un reconocimiento de verlo como
presidente de la república y hubo
muchísimo obstruccionismo dentro del
congreso para ello no lo dejaban viajar
para generar
alianzas importantes en la última fue
precisamente en México en donde Pues con
mucha Claridad pues pudo victimizarse
frente a presidentes latinoamericanos
según foro importantísimo de la alianza
Pacífico
sin embargo la capacidad o la nula
capacidad de Pedro castillo de enrumbar
el país con políticas públicas
lo han llevado a cavar su propia su
propia derrota su propia tumba No él
empieza con un clima de confianza más o
menos estable en sus primeros meses de
gestión pero pronto esta desaprobación
presidencial empezó a crecer cada vez
más incluso por sectores que votaron por
él pasó a preguntarle a Gabriela Quiero
conocer su opinión también sobre esta
posible persecución hubo persecución
desde su análisis la hubo o no
creo que sí En definitiva se te intentó
tumbar al al presidente como decía mi
primera intervención incluso desde antes
de haber llegado al sillón presidencial
Alexandra lo ha dicho también sin
embargo creo que ahí cabe una frase de
una expresión popular que que cabe para
el lado de Pedro Castillo como para el
de la oposición Y es que seas paranoico
no quiere decir que no te estén
persiguiendo No creo que el congreso se
sentía
en en una constante amenaza frente a la
posibilidad del cierre del Congreso y En
definitiva estaban siendo exagerados
estaban en No necesariamente viendo los
lugares correctos de las amenazas
pero a la misma vez la presidencia del
Consejo de ministros y el presidente
estaban considerando alternativas no
constitucionales entonces creo que
tenemos una oposición que adoptó en
muchas ocasiones comportamientos y muy
poco democráticos y muy bastante
obstruccionistas como ha señalado
Alexandra pero a la misma vez hemos
tenido un gobierno que
desde diferentes sectores altos cargos
ministros de estado ha cometido
presuntos actos de corrupción que se
siguen dilucidando Y entonces tenemos
la la paradoja de la que también habla
Alexandra de poder decir que
efectivamente se quería
retirar o tumbar a un presidente
Mientras que el presidente estaba dando
razones para hacer claro
digamos para para tener su propio
oposición exacto no y lo que hemos
tenido ayer creo que ha sido
la forma más evidente el final la
cristalización de de una de una
narrativa que levantaba derecha en el
que finalmente Pedro Castillo se dibuja
a sí mismo como un potencial dictador
sin éxito pero finalmente cumple la
narrativa que su oposición
había construido alrededor de él no Y la
oposición no tuvo que orquestar ningún
tipo de complot para poder llevar a su
destitución él mismo generó el escenario
perfecto para que eso ocurriera
Alexandra le pasó a preguntar justamente
por la oposición en esta situación es
siempre hay unos que ganan y otros que
pierden en este momento la oposición
está en una postura un poco más cómoda a
nivel político Cómo la pueden aprovechar
Qué ventaja pueden sacar de esta
situación los deja fortalecidos bueno Es
una muy buena pregunta sin lugar a dudas
es hoy se encuentra fortalecida la
oposición para ellos es un triunfo lo
que ha sucedido pero hay que recordar
también que muchos congresistas en
oposición que ayer celebraban la
vacancia Pedro Castillo en anteriores
ocasiones han mencionado de que no solo
iban a bajar a Pedro Castillo sino
también a Dina boluarte es decir Dina
boluarte no había todavía juramentado en
el poder y ya existían congresistas que
anunciaban que era necesario bajarla
Entonces vamos a vivir una especie de no
Primavera democrática pero sí verano
democrático estamos entrando ya en
verano en el Perú y hoy me imagino que
en un par de meses vamos a volver a ver
sentimientos o acciones poco
democráticas y obstruccionistas contra
la propia Dina boluar lo que le toca la
oposición ahora en realidad es tratar de
generar un consenso a favor del país
porque lo que hemos visto en la lección
que podía sacar tanto la derecha como la
izquierda en el Perú es que ante una
situación como esta Cada vez que
intentan ganar sus por sus propios
intereses particulares terminan
perdiendo más que ellos mismos no
Entonces lo importante aquí es que la
derecha sea consciente de que si muestra
dotes de apertura democrática de
generación de consensos de insertar
agendas y de hablar de debatir de
agendas de ideas a la solución de los
problemas públicos que es lo que
necesitamos y no tenemos pues la derecha
puede ganar mucho más piso para
fortalecerse Y lograr
salir elegidos en las próximas
elecciones pero mientras siga cometiendo
esta obstruccionismo lo único que van a
lograr es ser expectorados del panorama
electoral lo que vemos es como un déjà
Vu que se repite Y se repite y podemos
estar ante otro grande otro escenario de
una vacancia en los próximos meses por
eso hacía la pregunta al inicio del
programa Por cuánto tiempo podrá
gobernar Dina boluarte en este país
suramericano Gabriela hablemos ahora de
La otra cara de la moneda Como me gusta
decirlo en este programa y es la
izquierda peruana queda gravemente
herida después de este episodio
Cómo se presenta entonces en el panorama
político esta esta izquierda que llegó
con mucho después de unas elecciones muy
reñidas frente a keiko fujimori pero
como la deja después de esta de esta de
este episodio
creo que tenemos una izquierda bastante
golpeada estuvo golpeada de hecho antes
de las elecciones de 2021
la victoria de Pedro Castillo en primera
vuelta y el y su pase a segunda vuelta
Ya de por sí significaba La derrota de
un sector de la izquierda frente a una
que era más progresista un sector de la
izquierda más conservador no la segunda
vuelta se dio entonces entre dos fuerzas
bastante más conservadoras que sus
competidores Solo que de izquierda y de
derecha no
a la hora de poder ver el gobierno hemos
encontrado que fuerzas de izquierda
estuvieron del lado de Pedro Castillo en
la Constitución de su gobierno y a lo
largo de estos meses
la credibilidad de estas fuerzas
políticas que siguieron apoyando a Pedro
Castillo incluso hasta la mañana del día
de ayer ha ido cayendo credenciales
democráticas se van de alguna manera
diluyendo pero creo que una cosa que
deberíamos tener en el debate y poner
sobre la mesa también es como la
ciudadanía No necesariamente está de
lado ni de la derecha de oposición ni de
la izquierda
gobiernista o aliada del gobierno no
esta crisis y este escenario
si bien puede ser leído como una
victoria como señalaba Alexandra hace un
momento respecto del Congreso de la
República la verdad es que nos tiene en
medio de igual manifestaciones en contra
de Dina boluarte y de la izquierda la
que ella representa a gobiernista del
partido de Perú libre aunque ella no sea
miembro actual de esa agrupación
mientras que existen otras
manifestaciones en contra de El que es
permanecería en sus cargos entonces creo
que una de las cuestiones fundamentales
del momento que vivimos en el país es
una crisis de legitimidad de los actores
de gobierno a lo largo de todo el
espectro sí Gabriela Qué bueno que toque
Usted ese tema porque era justamente
hacia donde quería dirigir mi siguiente
pregunta antes de analizar la figura
política de Dina boluarte quería
analizar con ustedes el tema del
Congreso porque es que aquí está
desprestigiada y goza de muy poca
popularidad no solamente el presidente
también el congreso de Perú entre los
peruanos no goza de respeto ni de
popularidad entonces aquí prácticamente
ellos se han logrado proteger un poco y
han salido bien librados digamos de ese
descontento social porque había un foco
principal y era el presidente Era sobre
el que recaía la atención pero pero el
congreso no goza tampoco de prestigio
entre los peruanos y tiene una pésima
imagen debido a su a su mal rendimiento
y su mala labor aquí entonces los
ciudadanos Cómo van a pedir y a exigir
que haya un legislativo decente para
este país
Pues ese es el reto Ah perdón
adelante adelante Alexandra para hacer
la alternancia de como corresponde en
democracia entonces Alexandra y luego
Gabriela Sí pues ese es el reto que
tiene hoy El Congreso de aprovechar Este
cambio de Presidencia para mostrar
nuevos Aires y también un nuevos
comportamientos nuevos y mejores
comportamientos de Cara a la ciudadanía
no ahí soy un poco pesimista No creo que
realmente que el congreso vaya a mostrar
un cambio Genuino precisamente porque se
ha creído a Este triunfo como un triunfo
ganado y no como un triunfo pírrico no
en donde ellos también salen debilitados
de esta situación y en donde cada
decisión
antidemocrática que toman termina yendo
en contra de ellos mismos no entonces la
ciudadanía hoy Yo creo que necesita ser
muy consciente de que lo que necesitamos
no es un cambio de actores podemos
seguir hasta infinito cambiando congresi
cambiando presidentes y no vamos a salir
de la crisis en tanto no pensemos
realmente en una reforma que incluya un
cambio de comportamiento que incentive a
gente realmente honesta y comprometida
con el país a copar estos puestos que
hoy están copados con mafias que Solo
piensan en intereses particulares sin
embargo alguien que tiene o un sector
que tiene el el una gran responsabilidad
Aquí también son los medios de prensa
los medios de prensa en el Perú no van
contribuido por el contrario han
agudizado a la polarización en vez de
ser el espacio precisamente para la
generación del debate de ideas y de la
generación de una de una serie de
políticas públicas que tienen que ser de
una vez por todas implementadas y
continuadas en el país
Gabriela su opinión
creo que coincido plenamente con con lo
que con lo que se ha expuesto incluso
con lo que planteabas inicialmente la
mirada futuro corto y mediano plazo de
nuestro país pasa no solamente por el
desempeño de boluarte como presidente y
él la conformación de su gabinete que
podemos hablar un poquito más adelante
sino eh Por la
actuación del Congreso de la República
la manera en que tenga o no de cumplir
con esta Promesa sumada de aplausos el
día de ayer al reconocer a Dina boluarte
como la nueva presidenta en en nuestro
país sino también la capacidad que tenga
no solo de
no continuar con este rol
obstruccionista del que hemos venido
hablando sino de no continuar con la
perforación de reformas de de servicios
públicos y derechos ganados que ha
venido teniendo los últimos dos años no
este rechazo al congreso de la República
es un rechazo
que tiene su origen en comportamientos
antidemocráticos en acusaciones de
corrupción incluso asociaciones de
violencia sexual dentro de el mismo
hemiciclo no Entonces estamos hablando
de cosas muy concretas que no pasan
solamente por pensar en una oposición
crispada opcionista sino por un un poder
del Estado compuesto por en su en buena
parte individuos que no están asumiendo
su rol de servicio público no Y ese
rechazo que de hecho alcanza el 90 por
ciento
al congreso de la República es algo que
no va a cambiar de la noche a la mañana
y que como peruanos estamos a la
expectativa respecto de la manera en que
tanto el congreso como la ciudadanía y
los actores
de poder opinión pública prensa
organizaciones de la sociedad civil Irán
manifestándose respecto de la
permanencia del Congreso de la República
en sus poderes se Tal parece que la
incapacidad moral se extiende Más allá
del puesto del presidente y aplican
varios casos dentro del hemiciclo del
legislativo peruano Pero bueno eso le
corresponderá la justicia peruana
aclarar si es así o no hablemos de la
otra protagonista de esta historia
ustedes ya la estaban mencionando en
algunas de las intervenciones Dina
boluarte era hasta hace unas horas la
primera vicepresidenta de Perú hoy en
día se convierte en la primera
presidenta de este país suramericano
importante ver a una mujer
llegando a esta alta magistratura en en
un país latinoamericano pero en un
escenario muy complicado Y ustedes ya
han dicho algunos datos importantes no
goza de popularidad dentro de muchos de
los sectores políticos peruanos muy
difícil generar consensos llegar
Entonces hasta el 2016 como lo vio usted
Alexandra gobernará hasta el 2016 de
manera interina Dina boluarte y para los
que estamos fuera de las fronteras
peruanas quién es ella a nivel político
[Música]
tiene el mute activado y no la estamos
oyendo Alexandra Ahora sí
eso va a depender de la muñeca el manejo
político que ella pueda tener con la
oposición la gestión de los actores
dentro del panorama político es una
habilidad sumamente importante de todo
líder
democrático líder político en general no
ella en realidad bueno viene de las
contiendas de izquierda como candidata
ha tenido un perfil evidentemente muy
similar al de Pedro Castillo era muy
cercana a Vladimir cerrón que es un el
principal ideador de de Perú libre el
partido político por el cual Pedro
Castillo llegó al poder
sin embargo como ministra de estado ella
fue ministra de estado hasta hace poco
durante el gobierno de Pedro Castillo ha
sido ministra de desarrollo de inclusión
social y dentro de ese rol puedo
rescatar dos cosas primero que el midi
Celeste ministerio ha sido uno de los
pocos ministerios que todavía guardaba
cierto perfil técnico en algunos puestos
claves de dicho ministerio Entonces eso
es un punto a favor creo que ha sido
importante que ella respete la
experiencia y la meritocracia que puede
existir en estos puestos claves de este
ministerio y segundo en declaraciones a
la prensa siempre se ha mostrado con un
discurso mucho más concertador
diferenciándose de otros ministros que
por el contrario trataban más bien de
abrir mucho más La Brecha entre el
congreso y El Ejecutivo claro
y Gabriela qué significaba para Perú que
una mujer llegue al poder en la primera
mujer en la historia en asumir el cargo
de presidente en un escenario y en una
coyuntura muy complicada pero es
significativo para la historia del país
que una mujer llegue a este cargo
creo que sin duda es significativo creo
que llega más tarde de lo que muchas de
las mujeres y personas que creemos en la
equidad en la participación política
hubiéramos querido sin embargo un punto
relevante además y para hacer Matiz un
poco a la mirada que ha sido presentada
lo cierto Es que Dina boluarte ha
formado parte de
gabinetes ministeriales y del y ha
formado parte del gobierno que más
retroceso ha tenido en cuanto a paridad
por ejemplo en el en la elección de
ministros en diferentes sectores de El
Ejecutivo no entonces creo que esta este
hecho objetivo de cumplir el rol de ser
la primera mujer
que ejerza el rol de de presidente de la
República del Perú
es simbólico pero debe ser acompañado y
sería importante que sea acompañado de
una verdadera
representación femenina dentro de su
gabinete existen mujeres
que han formado parte de los diferentes
sectores existen personas que conforman
no y los ministerios que podrían acceder
estos cargos y creo que lo que sería
fundamental es que no estemos hablando
solamente de un símbolo y un hecho fue
un hecho anecdótico respecto de que ella
sea la primera persona la primera mujer
en asumir la presidencia sino que esté
acompañado de medidas que hablen de
políticas públicas y de acercamiento
hacia la igualdad de la participación
política y el acceso a cargos públicos
no me quedan ya solamente un par de
minutos para finalizar el programa
Alexandra Gabriela llega el momento de
hacer las conclusiones por supuesto para
el cierre del programa esto significa
Entonces el cierre de esta espiral de
crisis política de Perú o es simplemente
el cierre del capítulo Pedro castillo y
se abre ahora un nuevo capítulo y el
país va a seguir inmerso en estas en
estos escenarios de vacancias
presidentes ascensos descensos crisis
protestas malestar social cómo lo ve
usted Gabriela
creo que es una pregunta bastante
difícil no tengo una bola de cristal
para poder saber qué es lo que va a
pasar en nuestro país sin embargo
Lamentablemente sin duda la crisis
política excede al apellido castillo y
lo que hemos tenido Es simplemente en la
separación de uno de los actores
relevantes en esta crisis más no de
todos y además tampoco el cambio en las
estructuras los incentivos y las
organizaciones detrás de esta crisis
como le señalábamos es una crisis que
tiene que ver con valores que tiene que
ver con estructuras con incentivos con
prácticas entonces En definitiva estamos
culminando este este capítulo esta
temporada de de la crisis pero eh
continuamos intentando en esta esta
construcción democrática y me inclino a
pensar que efectivamente Seguiremos en
un escenario convulsionado pero no
necesariamente creo podríamos verlo como
un un movimiento que siempre tienda a un
escenario cada vez peor creo que existe
la posibilidad de construir
organizaciones y de tomar decisiones
sobre todo orientadas a la construcción
de colectivos y del fortalecimiento del
Estado para la entrega de servicios y el
cierre de brechas de desigualdad que
tenemos hoy en el Perú
la conclusión de Gabriela Alexandra para
el cierre del programa su conclusión
sobre la situación en su país pues si
bien la permanencia de Pedro Castillo en
el poder implicaba un costo muy alto
para la institucionalidad pública Lo
cierto es que una vacancia no soluciona
esta crisis que estamos teniendo
Lamentablemente creo que la crisis Va a
continuar en tanto la ciudadanía y los
medios de prensa no asuman un rol mucho
más activo y responsable para cambiar
precisamente no los actores sino los
comportamientos y los valores que hoy
están co de manera lamentable en los
puestos más importantes del país
Alexandra Gabriela Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros en el
debate de France 24 haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de France 24
Gabriela Gracias por usar el término de
la bola de cristal que lo cito
habitualmente en el programa y mis
compañeros aquí ya me hacen broma por
ello pero ya veo que está cogiendo
fuerza por fuera del estudio de France
24 muchas gracias a ustedes por la
sintonía En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros hoy la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Keila maestra y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Lina
Guzmán siga con nosotros
[Música]